the united kingdom we did not uh the
you ask about the ideas that are in the
white paper in fact
um ideas that are in the white paper
some of the uh ideas that are in the
white paper that perhaps have
caused uh most debate and discussion
following the chequers agreement and the
uh
publication of the white paper were
ideas that were
set out as potential issues for us to
look at
in the florence speech that i gave last
september
there had been discussions about these
throughout
and that was slightly fleshed out in the
mansion house speech that i gave earlier
this year
so those proposals were there and were
considered and looked at by
by ministers we took then decided the
route that we were going to uh to take
and we spent some time discussing that
with the
european commission and obviously in
terms of the negotiations with the
european union
um it became clear that that was not
negotiable alongside that of course we
were looking at the customs arrangements
um in relation to the two options that
had originally been on the table and
then refining
those two options to ensure that we
could deliver on the
uh frictionless trade at the border and
the no border with northern ireland
um what became clear was that it was
necessary to evolve
the mansion house position and in
advance of
that cabinet meeting there was
discussion about that uh that particular
issue
i say the underlying concept was one
that had been previously discussed
because it was there
actually in the lancaster not langston
has florence and then in the mansion
house speeches
and the law offices did you
ask them for their opinion in good time
as required by the ministerial code and
what was their response
well as uh i know sir william you will
know we don't uh
normally give in uh public details of
law officers opinions that are given to
the to the government
um but i can assure you that all those
who needed to be
uh involved in this and who needed to be
to look at this from their
responsibilities were
involved and that didn't include the law
officers
as a matter of fact the as a matter of
fact the the i mean the law officerism
is uh sits around the cabinet table and
is somebody who is uh
is consulted uh through that uh process
thank you um now the common rule book is
an eu rule book
the former president of the after court
has just very recently
last few days stated that under it and i
quote
the uk would recognize that the ecj
is supreme on the interpretation of eu
law
close quote available will determine
not only the interpretation but also the
outcome of any disputes
now under the similar ukraine georgia
and moldova treaties
the ecj in practice decides not the
arbitrators
so given what the former president of
the after court has so recently stated
and
i think it's generally understood that
he understands the stuff very well
how on earth could you argue that the
white paper does discontinue
discontinue ecj jurisdiction and how do
you recognize
reconcile as i asked you in the house
the other day
the repeal of the 1972 act
with the continuing application of the
functions of the european court of
justice
to the uk when as you won't know only
too well
section three of the european community
set 1972
is uh the jurisdiction of the european
court over the uk and domestic
law and under the repeal act that is
actually going to be repealed
on exit day uh
we acknowledge in the white paper the
role that the european court of justice
has
in being the determinant of the
interpretation of european union law
and that is acknowledged in the white
paper but we will not be under the
jurisdiction
of the european court of justice the uh
through the proposals that are
in here as we say in those cases where
there is a dispute which involves the
interpretation of eu law
and in the industrial goods a key of
course there is a significant
um volume a significant amount of of
case law already in existence in
relation
to the interpretation of those rules
many of which have not
have been stable have not changed for
some time uh
then it will be possible through those
processes to
uh ask for an opinion from
the european court of justice on the
interpretation of eu law
the european court of justice would not
determine any dispute
that takes place that that is in in uh
question at the time the court of one
party
cannot be the arbiter in terms of a
dispute between two parties
it would be there's a obviously we've
got the if you like the hierarchy
of determinations of disputes that that
takes place
the european court of justice by
definition as as
the arbiter of eu law would have an
influence but it would have an influence
in cases even when we had no deal with
the european union
because if you were a business that was
exporting to the european union
and doing so on the basis of eu rules
and there was a dispute
uh your importer for example raised a
dispute about
the interpret whether you had met those
eu rules the arbiter
of that eu rule would be the european
court of justice
in terms of disputes that are breaking
before the courts in the uk
they will go to the uk courts they will
be determined by the uk courts
i understand that that is the direction
the trajectory of your answer
but i still leave on the table the
questions i've asked and i remain
unconvinced at the moment but we shall
continue this while no doubt in due
course
i suspect william you and i might have
some further lengthy discussions on some
of these
i think we're going to have to move on
to the next section thank you very much
um so the next chair is uh bernard
jenkins so bernard jenkins the chair of
the public administration and
constitutional affairs
thank you very much um and good
afternoon prime minister
absolutely um the the white paper talks
about
stepping up plans for no deal and um
so far there appears to have been some
reticence about
making announcements about what is being
prepared for in the event
of no deal so what's the basis for
deciding when to announce
what is being done in preparation for no
deal
well i think i mean there are two uh two
approaches that we all two aspects that
we've looked at the first is obviously
the work that needs to be done
uh by the government in determining the
preparations
and then the second is the point at
which it is
important to be able to ensure that
others outside government who would need
to be involved
are able to have the information that
they need i was going to
um look we're not yet on the uh the
debate later
technical notifications to set out what
uk
citizens and businesses need to do in a
no deal uh scenario
so making much more public awareness of
the
of the preparations um we imagine
they're going to be
around 70 of those technical notices
that would that will be issued
so that's if you like taking a next step
the cabinet did agree that we need to
step up our no deal preparations but
this is part of those no deal
preparations
is making those technical notices
available to those who need to obviously
need to know
uh that information thank you so if
we're um
you ruled out the option of negotiating
an fta with the
european union because they won't
negotiate with us
on the basis of the without the backstop
they weren't countenance in fta
without the backstop that's correct
isn't it well yes if i may just but this
is where language
is um is important um we
if we say if we talk about a free trade
agreement then the european union has a
single concept of what a free trade
agreement is
so it's like canada that's a free trade
agreement what we're talking about
in here is a much wider and more
ambitious overall partnership with them
so obviously as at its heart as a free
trade area with the
with the eu um but that's why we don't
use the work
the term free trade agreement but you're
right the two options
that were on the table from the eu were
on the one hand eea plus
free movement customs union um and which
i think would
would not reflect that and on the other
was a free trade agreement that actually
was less good than the canadian free
trade agreement
but with effectively the border down the
rsc one of the reasons you've given for
not
going for a canada plus plus plus free
trade agreement is
that they won't negotiate with us on the
basis of the
of northern ireland remaining in the
same customs area as the rest of the
united kingdom they won't do that will
they
they the their proposal was for a
free trade agreement which actually
split northern ireland okay so
if we have a wto brexit with or without
an agreement a withdrawal agreement can
you give us an assurance that it will be
on the basis of a wto brexit
that is for the whole of the united
kingdom and there is no question
of splitting ireland from the rest of
the united kingdom
under their circumstances well i have
been um
uh i've said on many many occasions
that one of the
targets one of the aims that i have in
relation to
the negotiations that we have is to
ensure that we retain the united kingdom
together
i believe that is important i believe
our union is very precious so
i will certainly be working to ensure
that we are able to maintain
the united states as i said in response
to
earlier questions that's fine in a no
deal scenario
of course we will have to consider what
action we take others will have to
consider what actions they take
the no deal planning or the wto brexit
planning is planning for an invisible
frontier in northern ireland
the uh planning that is taking place at
the moment the issue of
the issue of the uh what happens in
relation to that is an element that we
have to
to be looking at as we're undertaking
the no deal planning
the preparatory work that is being
undertaken
um is being undertaken across a whole
range of departments and the whole
relationship
because i've already answered a question
like this and i don't want to be any
misunderstanding between
the answers that i'm giving to the same
question but is is the government
planning
for a no frontier invisible customs
frontier in northern ireland
because you have to that's part of the
no deal planning as we look at the no
deal planning
one of the elements one of the issues
that we have to look at is
one of the elements that we are looking
at as part of our no deal planning
is that whole question of of the border
in northern ireland
okay i don't think we're going to get
any further on that one um
and for matters such as the regulation
of chemicals aviation safety food safety
and indeed medicines which
the house commons voted on yesterday
presumably
planning no deal planning includes draft
legislation in order to provide for
regulation of those products in our own
market
and when are we going to see that
legislation no no deal planning
will um in does involve looking at the
any legislative requirements that are
needed for these points
there is um i don't have a timetable for
that those legislative any
required legislation at the moment we
have already put through some
legislation
that is relevant in a no deal scenario
in terms of our
our preparations um for uh leaving the
eu
uh the but there is work that is
undertaken for example in
the relation to erza in terms of
ensuring
you would be looking for example uh
there
at possibly probably a set of bilateral
agreements
and department of transport is is
looking at that but i mean uh um
we will have to probably use the
provisions under the withdrawal
eu withdrawal act um and we'll have to
have regulations under the
that act in order to replace those
functions and if
and let's hope that they give us those
bilateral agreements because it would be
very destructive and vindictive if they
would
they did not but um when can when do you
think we will see those draft
regulations or
draft acts of poland draft bills well
there are some of the
um uh look there's going to be a whole
range of um exit uh
there'll be a whole range of legends
primary and secondary legislation
that will be being brought forward over
over time obviously
there are a number of um as i said we've
already passed
obviously withdrawal out the nuclear
safeguards bill the sanctions build
we're expecting to lay approximately um
40
eu exit sis um uh before recess
this is the the work is ongoing there is
this significant number of
sis that need to be laid in all of these
areas thank you very much prime minister
thank you we come onto the transport
committee now and lillian greenwood
thank you um prime minister i'm sure
that like many people you're
looking forward to jetting off on
holiday we even understand you were
quite keen to get away early
obviously one of the things happens is
that people um when they come back from
their holidays they want to walk their
flights for next year and at the moment
that's looking
very uncertain last autumn the secretary
of state was confident
that the government would have made
clear progress by
but on aviation we've yet to see
anything concrete how close are we
to having the necessary post-brexit
aviation arrangements
in place to retain access to the eu's
single av
market well the the as we've set out in
the white paper
we want to uh as part of the future
relationship
explore options that would enable the uk
to continue to participate
in the iniasa as a non-eu member state
um we're moving at pace in terms of
negotiations as i've said in relation to
the future framework because we want
that
in in to be sufficiently complete by
the uh autumn of this year not
uh legal text potent uh obviously full
legal texts to follow
thereafter um the we believe that uh
what is in this uh white paper is the
right package we can put forward as i've
said
what the department of transport are
also doing and looking at what would
happen in a no deal scenario
and what arrangements would need to be
placed in a no deal scenario in order to
ensure
look i mean grounded planes are in no
one's
interest no we were told they're very
unlikely so you've said now
potentially autumn and i know does it
all to me
september does it mean october does it
mean november does it mean december
what's holding up progress on a deal on
this vital area
oh it's going to be part of the future
relationship
the future relationship has been put
which we published in the white paper
has been put to the european union
we've started having discussions with
the european union on the basis of that
future relationship
the timetable that everybody is working
to is to have that future relationship
agreed in sufficient detail by october
such that
when this parliament looks at withdrawal
agreement and implementation bill it
will know what the the uh details of the
future relationship
will be that's the timetable so the
secretary of state confirmed that the
aviation industry would need
comfort that we're making progress by
next summer
last october he told us that when it was
this summer well we're well into summer
shouldn't we have had some of those
things nailed down by now
well as i say the department of
transport is working with the aviation
industry
to ensure that the necessary
arrangements will be in place
we have made a specific proposal in here
about yaza and participation in the yaza
as part of the future relationship and
that future relationship is being
negotiated
as we in as i said with that timetable
that was set of october um it is
in as you say it's in everybody's
interest to ensure that the planes
can still fly i think that's well not
just in our interest it's in the
interests of others
so progress by summer and now you're
saying that slipped
to the autumn no i'm not saying that
that progress has
slipped the autumn i'm saying this is an
ongoing negotiation
uh of a variety in a variety of levels
the future relationship is being
negotiated with the european commission
with the view to that agreement by
october
the department of transport have already
also been discussing
with a number of uh of countries the
arrangements that could be put in place
if there is no agreement on a
multilateral basis
for with the united kingdom for those
proposals
to ensure that whatever the outcome is
that the planes can still fly so are we
proposing are we
in negotiations on bilateral agreements
with
each of the 27 eu countries in addition
to other
international bodies we're we're
we're in discussion where it is
necessary to be in discussion to ensure
that if there is no deal this is part of
no deal preparations
that the planes can fly but if there is
uh
what we're proposing here is an
arrangement that would enable
that to continue to happen in the
circumstances in which we have a deal
as part of the deal alongside that i
mean it's not just the department of
transport obviously the civil aviation
authority
is also working with the aviation sector
it's making
the preparations that are necessary um
for it
obviously we propose participation in
yaza but is also making the preparations
necessary
were it to be the case it had to operate
outside yaza okay
why isn't the government got on and
struck a good aviation deal with the u.s
with some concessions if necessary to
leverage
uh progress with the eu and provide some
certainty
to the airline industry and passengers
are there sticking points in
negotiations with
the united states and if so what's
holding up progress
uh on the deal with the us on open skies
we've had a number of uh rounds of
negotiations with the united
states on this issue we're confident
that we will be reaching an agreement
with them
and when we ex when are we expecting
wouldn't it have been good to have got
that deal
in place in order to put more pressure
on the eu to reach
uh agreement about the uk eu arrangement
we
will we will conduct the negotiations
and put the arrangements in place
uh when they need to be put in place so
does that mean that people when they
come back from their holiday perhaps in
a few weeks at a time they're going to
be buying flights or they might be
thinking about booking next year's
holiday and they really don't know
whether those flights will operate or
not whether there'll be any arrangement
in place to give them the certainty
about booking their holiday
well there are if as you will recall
first of all
we do look at what is going to be in
place post march
2019 but of course we also have an
implementation period up to the end of
december 2020
um and we are looking to the
relationship that will be in place
uh at the end of that implementation
period some things could be
brought in place put in place at an
earlier stage
within that implementation period that
the department of transport is working
with
the aviation sector with governments
within
and outside the european union and also
as we've put forward this is for a
negotiation with the eu 27 collectively
uh we think that's the the right way
forward with the deal but we are making
the preparations necessary to ensure
that whatever
the circumstances whatever happens in
terms of the outcome
of the negotiations we still have those
arrangements for planes to fly
so put your flight at your own risk i
think thank you
very much thank you moving on now to the
environment food and rural affairs
committee and neil parish
thank you thank you chairman and good
afternoon prime minister i think the
answer is to come to the west country
to holiday and not worry about the
flights um there must be times when you
you feel that you're damned if you
negotiate with the eu and you're damned
if you if you don't
um and so i actually very much welcome
your
your decision at checkers and the
cabinet and the white paper on
agri-food because i think rules need to
be dealt with
we've got a 30 of our manufacturing
industry in this country is food and
drink much of that food
is grown here um and under very good
welfare conditions and
and and environmental conditions also
the northern ireland border i think is
um and the republic much of the trade
between the two
is food and it's perishable and it
crosses the border several times
but my actual question to you is is on
on fishing
and that is you know at the moment the
fishing industry is it contributes 1.3
billion to the economy
34 000 jobs and and 708 000 tons of fish
are are caught and and we do process a
lot of that so to our coastal
communities and fishermen
it's very important but the issue is
that as we leave the eu
and we become an independent coastal
state at the moment they take some
something like six times the amount of
fish from our waters
as we take from theirs and so it's an
ace card if you like in our our pack as
we negotiate
now our fishermen want to make sure they
get their fish back
and what they want to hear you know very
clearly from you
is that as we do this negotiation
they're not going to have their fish
negotiated away
because we can not only get that fish
back but we can also actually build up
our coastal communities our processing
and it can be a really positive step for
from leaving
the european union so you know this is a
reassurance
i seek first first point we will be out
of the common fisheries policy and we
will come out of the common fisheries
policy
and we will be acting as an independent
coastal state yes
um of course there are issues about
actually fishing and then there's the
question of fishing products and
and uh the access to markets in relation
to fishing products
but in terms of uh the uh access to
waters
that our fishermen would uh would have i
mean we
we want to be sitting there as an
independent coastal state
able to make obviously as you'll be
aware there are
annual negotiations um not just i mean
obviously it's the eu structure within
the common fisheries policy but more
generally annual
negotiations about access to waters and
we will be part of that as an
independent stage
and we are very careful at the way
in which fishing has been approached in
the white paper so that it
is separate from um the question
of that uh other elements of the
economic partnership
precisely because i recognize the
concern that the fishing industry had in
the uk
when we went into the european that's
right there's no doubt
the fishing industry lost out
dramatically i think it's just that
fishermen are bound to be slightly
worried that it's tempting when you're
sitting down
around the negotiating table there's
some sticking points on other issues on
trade
that you start negotiate away some of
that extra fish and
i accept that it may take one or two
years to get there but the fishermen
want to be absolutely certain they're
going to get their fish back
and it's not going to get traded away so
we are going to be
ensuring that the control of our natural
resources is distinct from the
negotiation of the future economic
partnership
so we can the official one can be
assured that they're going to get their
fish back
separate negotiation
so it'll be a separate negotiation in a
separate part of the agreement right so
so therefore it's not going to be a
bargaining tool you can say that quite
clearly as we as we negotiate out of the
eu
because the eu want greater access to
our fish
because they've got it at the moment so
they're bound to try and play hardball
on it oh we want this to be this will be
a separate agreement a separate part of
the negotiations that we're
we're undertaking with them this is not
going to be jumbled in with the
with the other elements of the with the
elements of the trade
relationship in the way that it was in
the past so fishermen
can rest easy in their beds we want to
we want to ensure that as you say we not
only
restore the independence of the uk
in terms of determining access to its
waters but we also
have the opportunity as you say to see
our fishing communities being built up
and the the benefits that that will
bring and of course a very final
question is that as we get those fishing
rights back and that fish back of course
the pro quo is a lot of that is traded
into the european union so therefore the
deal
on making sure the agri-food market
works
on an extremely perishable product
is even more important yes thank you
thank you um just before we move on to
the next section on air quality can i
just uh
ask you a further point about um
contingency planning because
you you've mentioned in an earlier
answer to sir bernard
that you'll be issuing technical notices
in august and september so those who
need to know
what about the wider public what sort of
information will you be giving the wider
public
about all the different contingencies
you're planning for
in the event of no deal and and the
costs that would be involved in that
will you be
very clear and transparent with
everybody about the range of areas
where you will be making preparations
and making that information available to
the public
well i think we will be making more
information available generally
about the um preparations that are being
made the technical notices are obviously
very
specific to those who need to
consider how they personally or their
business is preparing
for uh the uh potential circumstance of
no deal
um but by making those available i mean
obviously we will be that will be part
of
uh in making more information available
more generally on the preparations that
are taking place
but as lillian greenwood has pointed out
there are very many
wide-ranging areas in which no deal
would not be better than a bad deal
where there could be very significant
impacts on on individuals will you be
setting those out so the public can see
what the potential implications could be
i mean we've we've for example on the
health committee looked at
very many implications for example if we
don't have access to
um the the european health insurance
card
after after we leave the european union
in the event of no deal whatsoever
it would effectively mean that people
with long-term health conditions
would be uninsurable to travel to the
european union
are these the kinds of areas that you'll
be laying out to people
well i think the the um if i may there's
a
uh an issue here where we're looking to
negotiate a deal
and negotiate that by october so
and at that point of course the question
will come to uh the question will come
to parliament
um as to uh on the we have the
meaningful vote we then have
uh if uh the potential wave the
withdrawal agreement and implementation
bill um
at the point at which it is uh
and at that point with a deal and an
agreed deal then obviously
it will become clear to people what the
future relationship is going to be
and the basis basis of that that future
relationship
i think if you're asking me to say are
we going to say to people
here and now um if there is no deal you
will not be able to do a b and c
i mean what is what preparedness for no
deal
is is about is making sure that
government
that business that those who have to
take actions to prepare
for no deal are able to do that um
and do that in a timely way because some
of these may be
actions which would take time to put
into place that's right but it's also
about letting the public know
well in advance what the kinds of issues
will be arising for every government
department and for them in their
everyday lives as well
well i think there's at the point
if it were to be the case we're working
for a deal we're working for a good deal
we all appreciate if it were to be the
case that
we were to be in a no deal scenario then
obviously the information
that that it would be necessary for the
public to
have would be made available to them but
the point is that it looks as if we're
getting closer towards the possibility
of no deal everyone appreciates that you
would like to
uh to achieve a good deal we all re
realize that
but this is about setting out very
clearly what the consequences of no deal
would be
what the planning necessary for that
would be
and what the potential costs would be so
that's very clear to the public
well you based your question on an
assumption that uh said that we were
getting closer
to a no deal scenario i i don't believe
that is the case we are
have put forward a uh proposal for what
the future relationship should be
we believe the future relationship
should be with the european union
and we're in negotiations on the basis
of that the timetable
that i've set out in answer to other
questions still remains in relation to
working
to having sufficient detail of this uh
for agreed by october
okay so i accept you don't you don't see
the except the premise of my question
but there is still that that growing
possibility i feel that we could end up
with a no deal scenario
and my question was will you be laying
out for the public what the consequences
of that will be very clearly
if if we are in a no deal scenario then
we will lay out the consequences
for the public we are doing what we are
doing at the moment
is working for a deal appreciate that
but
what we're doing is working for a deal
and
that is the basis of on which the
chequers agreement was made that's basis
on which the white paper is made it's
based on which we've started discussions
with the european union
um so at this point what we're doing is
saying we will ensure
as we step up our no deal preparations
we will ensure that those technical
notices are issued over august and
september
so that those who need to have that
information you have made that make sure
that they do respond i think what you're
asking me to do
is to do something else which is to set
out the argument for no deal
versus the argument for a deal rather
than actually saying we're working for a
deal no i'm asking we make sure that
prime minister with respect that's not
i'm asking you to set out for the public
because i i think sometimes the public
don't realize the
scale of the issues that we would be
facing
um and the costs and the and the
absolute necessity that we start
planning now because time is getting so
short
so i guess my um my request to you is
will you agree
to publish this um so that the public
can see what the consequences are and
what you're planning for
what what we will be doing is ensuring
that more information is available on
the preparations the government is
making for no deal
that we publish the technical notices so
that those
who need to make the preparations for no
deal
are able to do so you have said you've
made that clear prime minister it's my
concern was for the wider public
understanding what the consequences are
um but anyway we're going to move on now
to entirely different subject
um and that is air quality and opening
the questioning um
yourself a lydian agreement um prime
minister i'm sure you know
our four committees produced a report
which called for a joined up approach
from government on air quality including
improving public transport and
incentives to reduce the need for
private vehicle
use now your government has a policy
just after
four o'clock what we're seeing on your
screen
is the prime minister answering
questions from the liaison committee
this tends to happen uh during every
parliamentary session questions from the
chairman
of the various select committees uh mrs
may's come under quite a lot of
uh scrutiny interesting that she says
she does not believe
uh that the uk is moving closer uh to a
no deal
brexit earlier she was being questioned
in detail about how her
proposed customs arrangements would work
and really struggled to give specific
answers as she did there
on the whole question of the european
health card
so brexit continues to put pressure on
the prime minister
and uh as if to underline that while
she's been speaking to
mps in a committee room boris johnson
the former foreign secretary delivered a
personal
uh resignation speech in which he
said that the dream
of a brexit was being lost
in which he said what was proposed at
checkers
was brexit in name only
and in which he urged the prime minister
to return to the principles which he
said she laid out
in her lancaster house speech at the
beginning of last year
it is not too late
to save brexit we have time
in these negotiations we have changed
tap
once and we can change again yeah the
problem is not
that we failed to make the case for a
free trade agreement of the kind
spelled out at lancaster house we
haven't
even tried we must try now
because we will not get another chance
to get it right
well monitoring the latest brexit
developments is our senior political
correspondent
jason farrell jason let's start with
that
resignation speech from boris johnson
was it a sir jeffrey house speech an
all-out assault
on the prime minister's leadership or
not
well it wasn't quite an all-out assault
on theresa may he praised her for her
courage
and resilience but it was an assault on
her policy and i also think an attack on
the way that in which she has conducted
these negotiations so not just saying
that she's going in the wrong
wrong direction but pretty much also
criticizing
the backstory to these negotiations in
particular where
he talked about a fog of self-doubt and
he said that we have
burned up sorry burned our way through
our negotiating capital with 18 months
of stealthy
retreat and he compared the lancaster
house speech to
the chequers agreement and really made
three key comparisons firstly about the
common rule book
with the chequers agreement and how the
language to how house speech she talked
about uh
creating our own rules then talked about
voting on rules the ability for
parliament to have a say on rules
and saying that now we would become rule
takers and then in the lancaster house
speech
specifically picking on the comments you
said about not being half in
or half out he said now of course we
would be in lockstep
with the european union on our rules
over
goods and agri-foods so it was a
complete attack
on uh theresa may i didn't think it had
as much metaphor
as jeffrey howell did with that famous
qriket bat suggestion that we were going
into bat
with broken bats um as you might expect
from boris johnson
and it wasn't striking a killer blow
saying that she should stand down
but it was saying there was time to
change tack
and clearly a suggestion from boris
johnson that he felt he could do a
better job in this negotiation than
theresa may good
he did evoke the thatcherite free market
reforms of the 1980s and he said they
wouldn't be possible
on the other hand those were carried out
when britain was a member of the
european community so what's his point
there
well i think he the point he's he is
making is that there is
this is a this is a backtrack on the
idea of
free markets around the world and free
trading around the world
uh that he doesn't believe theresa may
uh when she says that there will be this
ability
to strike our own free trade deals
outside of
the european union he says that will be
giving away too much
uh capital with this agreement on goods
uh
and agri foods and that uh the the idea
that he
put forward of course uh during the
referendum campaign
uh that britain would strike it out and
become
this independent nation that that was uh
that had effectively died over the last
18 months of these negotiations
what about the reception for the speech
i have to say just here in the comments
i don't get the impression that this
resignation speech
has really electrified the political
debate today would that be fair
well it was weird it was i mean it
wasn't as there was obviously a buffer
put between theresa may
giving her having the prime minister's
questions they had this
the various urgent questions in the
comments between theresa may and boris
johnson then because when he got up to
stand
to make his speech theresa may was
nowhere in the in the house in fact she
was
sitting down ready to take those
questions that we've been watching from
the liaison committee
um but he did have a kind of buffer of
the key kind of brexiteers around him
the big supporters i noticed david davis
uh sat directly behind him and uh you
could see that he had
surrounded himself by a fair number of
backers if you like the kind of people
who you might expect to come out in
support of him if he did ever stand for
a leadership
but no it wasn't a rousing uh bring down
the house speech
i didn't feel uh from boris johnson but
i'm not sure
it didn't seem that exactly that he was
aiming for it he was putting down a
marker
uh effectively saying that you know this
is the way it's got
to go if it doesn't go that way then
we're not putting forward the brexit
that the public have asked for and in
particular
the conservative party membership who he
has been polling
uh himself to see how popular he is
amongst the conservative membership and
apparently finding that he's more
popular than perhaps people would expect
and there is that sense that he is uh
sending out that message to
the conservative heartlands uh that he
is ready to step in
if he gets the feeling uh that that is
what is wanted
of course it's a very busy day for the
prime minister uh she's giving that
evidence session now having to hear
about boris johnson and then she's gonna
go on and meet her own mps behind closed
doors
at the 1922 committee here in the palace
of westminster
and she's already done a session of
prime minister's
questions where it has to be said some
of the toughest questions
came from her own side the conservative
benches
i'm going to go